mais ce soir je tenais à me faire un
cadeau ce cadeau il va arriver sur scène
dans un instant avant regardent ils se
déplacent actuellement tu peux te
retourner regarde deux billets d'avion
le cadeau est là ah la la yan tu ne le
sait peut-être pas regarde-moi autour de
toi regarde devant et les
téléspectateurs ne savent certainement
pas mais j'ai développé depuis quelques
semaines des talents de mentaliste
oui yan tu vas me regardes et tu vas me
déplacer tu me regardera toujours je
suis la liane tu n'entends avoir rien
que ma voix yan tu vas penser très fort
à une personne tout de suite une
personne pense à une personne n'y a
quelqu'un que tu ne peux peut-être pas
voir tous les jours
pense à cette personne
tu as cette personne en toi le tigre est
en toi alors évidemment par quelqu'un
qui habite à l'autre bout de la planète
ce serait un peu compliqué et pense à
quelqu'un que tu ne peux pas voir tous
les jours diallo est ce que tu as des
enfants
non on va t'en faire le 7 c'est bizarre
parce que je te le dis plus tu me
regarde plus je sais à qui tu penses
ouais et touches sont avalés pas loin
aller juste derrière moi récents jeux
sans lien avec une personne jeune ou est
très jeune et je sais que c'est une
adolescente
oui tu as de la famille dans le coin non
elle est un peu loin mais si vous l'avez
fait venir ça vous êtes fort à une
petite soeur à nos une nièce une nièce
c'est quelqu'un qui compte beaucoup pour
toi ah bah oui c'est oui c'est quoi
c'est massima seul nièce à qui j'en ai
parlé que c'est comme sa fille
alors
mais puisque hadjez sauf qu'elle serait
capable de venir du canada spécialement
oui elle en est capable
bien sûr elle serait très contente ça
s'appelle comment elle s'appelle inès tu
as envie de la voir ce soir rapide au
pardon voudra dire on va dire pas trouvé
un allié en culotte mais en fait je me
je vais vous dire la vérité je me fais
un peu de souci parce que j'ai j'avais
pas trop de nouvelles depuis deux trois
jours
puis je me dis tiens c'est bizarre elle
répond pas mais sms et tout et j'ai
trouvé ça bizarre et se voit là ce soir
j'allais vraiment dire viens avec moi oh
vous êtes quand même incroyable tu vois
c'est mieux que jean pierre foucault
elle est le roc tuer mais de dire la
vérité chérie
oui est ce que tu me parles d'une
personne à septèmes avec moi jamais rien
ne se passe normalement à je suis pas
sûr que ce soit la personne dont tu
parles à
alors là c'est toi qui va décider
d'ouvrir le cadeau tu aimerais voir inès
match non mais tu nous parles
ça peut pas être comme ma fille c'est ma
nièce dont tout est vrai que c'est parce
que je l'adoré que je suis sonné chez
opel on peut changer la boîte en
pressant gelabale battue peut offrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cible
d
[Musique]
mais non
m
[Applaudissements]
je suis merci nes d'être là je mentais
contente de te voir tu attends toujours
mais elle a dit oui tout de suite c'est
à dire oui mais oui je sais que hyper
contente de la voir elle est vraiment
c'est une bonne question
c'était comme une folle de l'avoir oui
sinon c'est quand même pas devenu un
phare et la wii non mais le truc c'est
que sur tout alors on a passé l'été une
partie de l'été ensemble ce que j'étais
en tournée dans le sud donc elle est
venue et puis et puis on s'est dit bon à
bientôt et le prochain bientôt c'était
les fêtes de noël voilà l'ambiance à
l'avoir maintenant il sait 13
[Applaudissements]